onyx looking really good here
do something
no
orbital oh my god so close don't get hit
by ray drive
follow you now
he's dead
ah
brother on four
follow up you got a lot of time
afterwards but that was pretty gangster
nice combo
is that enough running exploder into the
mid oh
time it oh no oh my god he holds on
that was three
trouble in paradise let's see next star
will he be oh that's a big block that's
a huge block he's gonna get the wall as
well
but what what's the option he goes to
the ground throw
oh my gosh it might be over rip it might
be over oh
damn see you later x-star moving on to
the wall but it's gonna do decent damage
let's see what the mix-up is soccer
with
kick
and
another one there's the launch though he
might be dead he might be dead
not close 50 50
low
i have the rate drive back
one
thirty seconds left
oh he was like he's huge
it's gonna it's he's not gonna be
enraged he's not gonna be rage let's see
what he does now he's in right i'm in
the rage
and he's still living last week's oh my
god
my god
[Music]
[Music]